ovid 19 vaccine rollout does continue
here in the silver state
the southern nevada health district is
now scheduling appointments for more
front line workers
orco mana explains who is eligible and
what officials are planning next
we're excited because i mean we deal
with the most vulnerable
juan salinas with the salvation army
southern nevada is getting his first
dose of the coven 19 vaccine this
weekend
he says staff has done everything from
setting up shelters
to providing daily meals in person
throughout the pandemic
interaction with the clients on a daily
basis and we need to be there
we don't have that option to just work
from home he joins a list of southern
nevadans who as of monday are now
eligible for the vaccine under the
category front line community support
that includes teachers food bank
employees and public transportation
drivers
we are all working around the clock to
ensure that we can get it into as many
arms as possible
clark county commission chair marilyn
kirkpatrick tells me about 2 000 people
are getting vaccinated daily at the
cashman center mega site
and things are looking promising for
umc's new site at the encore
we anticipate they'll be able to do
about a thousand
a days the plan now is to get more mass
vaccination sites up and running
potential locations include fiesta
henderson and even allegiant stadium
but there's no timeline yet a lot of it
is dependent on how many doses that we
get from vaccines so
every day i want to be able to clean my
shelf so that i can tell the federal
government i need more and more and more
so that's the goal salinas's goal is to
keep his staff safe while continuing
their important work
we can look at a new beginning in 2021
orco mana 8 news now now as orco was
talking about their teachers are able to
sign up for the vaccine there's a
specific education point of dispensant
that's being set up at unlv and we're
told
it'll be ready to go next week now